人間が引き寄せられるのは魅力に引き寄せ
られるんですよね。だ僕がどうしたら人を
安く使えるかってことをいつも考えていた
としたら相手からみたいな魅力のない経営
者に成り下がっちゃうわけじゃない。経営
者って働く人のこと考えなきゃいけないと
思うんですよ。青木サの人生学100回
聞いたら豊かになる話。今回はですね、
採用が弱い会社の特徴は何かというところ
ですね。
採用の強い会社と採用の弱い会社の違いって何かっていうことについて教えていただけます。
うん。それあの大学生、新卒、
そうですね。大学の新卒業。
うん。新卒業ね。うん。
[音楽]
シンプルにそれは大学生から見て魅力のない会社ってことでしょ。
僕は前から言ってるけれど結局魅力あの
磁石が吸い寄せられるのは磁力に引き寄せ
られるじゃないだ。人間が引き寄せられる
のは魅力に引き寄せられるんですよね。
じゃあその魅力って何かって言うと本当に
将来性があって自分は物心両面豊かに
なれるという確信それがやっぱりある1つ
の魅力なんだと思うんだよね。あとは、ま
、裁量が与えられる。自分のしたいことが
できる。自分の価値観にあっているその
反対に言われたことだけやっとけばいいん
だよとか。だから裁量与えられなかったり
から安い報酬でコき使おうとか休みも
少なく福利構成も不十分そして給料も安い
。これ魅力ないよね。働く人の立場に立っ
て考えたら魅力っていうのは作られるんだ
と思う。だからアチューメントって今新入
社員大学の新卒を取ると33万円の初人級
ですよね。で、33万が安いか高いかって
のは人それぞれの見方もあると思うんだよ
。でも諸外国から見たら33万って決して
高くないんですよ。韓国でも345万って
言われてるよね。アメリカなんかシリコン
バレーなんか言ったらものすごく高いわけ
で。いや、僕は今回あの南アフリカ旅行し
たんだけど物価の高さにびっくりしました
。ちょっとしたあのスパゲティみたいの
頼んだら4000円とかなのよ。これは
報酬、あの給与が高いっていうか、ま、
チップにしてもそうだけど全体的に高いの
は当たり前だよねって。なぜなら生活の
物価そのものが高いんだもん。日本って
本当に安いんだよ。逆に言うと日本って
ある意味で今はまだね、もちろん先進国で
ね、指導的立場にある豊かな国だけど値段
は世界的に見たら外食なんかは安すぎる
ぐらいですよ。でもそれは余賃
払えないじゃん。だ、僕はやっぱり経営者
って働く人のこと考えなきゃいけないと
思うんですよ。付加価値の高い仕事をして
得た利益を分配をする。労働分配率を
いかに高くするかっていうことを本気で
考えない経営者はおそらく働く人から見て
魅力がないんだと思う。だって何年勤めて
も報酬上がらないとか、それこそ今収支
雇用制度をね、だんだんだんだん今変わっ
てきてるけれども、まあ相当の年齢に行か
ないと部長になれないとか役になれないと
言ったらいやあ、魅力感じなんじゃないの
?今の若い人たちは私はそういう意味で
うちの会社がなんで今若い人から見てもね
、働きがアワード上位常に良い評価もらえ
てるかって言うと働く人の立場に立って
考えてるからだよね。やっぱり経済的にも
精神的にも豊かにしてあげたいという私の
思いから仕組みが生まれてくるので今期は
過去最高業績ですから過去最高業績って
いうことは労働分配率も過去最高になる
わけでそこに見通しをみんな持ってくん
じゃないの自分の毎年毎年農量開発をして
自分がマインドノーハウスキルが高まって
それに合わせて報酬もポジションも上がっ
ていけるるっていうのがやっぱり見通しな
んじゃないですか。うん。だから魅力の
ない会社っていうのはそれを与える努力を
していない。うん。だ休みも少ないから
仕事のやりがいもない。それから職場の
人間関係も良くない。楽しくない。仕事が
マネジメントの質が悪くてやらされている
。そんな状態ではやっぱり離職も起き
ちゃうだろうし、それはもう募集費いくら
かけても水質変えない限りその会社は働く
人から見て魅力を感じない会社だよね。誰
のせいなのかと。社長です。全ては社長の
責任です。アチュメントも、ま、正直5%
未満だけど、ま、5%近く、例えば今うち
240人でしょ。ってことは年間で10人
ぐらいはあるでしょう。でもいい人やめて
ないもん。じゃあどういう人がやめてる
かって言うと、比較をしてあいつにはか
勝てないなとか、それから比較でなんか
こう葛藤してるとか、それからなんだろう
、うちの仕事の内容から見て長期的、本質
的、客観的に見て長く自分はできないなと
そういう風に思ってしまう人だ。その上が
ないわけだよね。トレーナーになって
トレーナーなんていくつだってできるわけ
だし、だからこう自分で見通しを持てるか
どうかって仕事の適正がない人はやっぱり
早期離職してくよね。でもそれは悪いこと
じゃないと。寂しいことではあるけど悪い
ことではないと。私はある意味で本当に
社員を幸せにしようと思って経営している
と心からそう思ってそのにふさわしい報酬
体系と人事効果制度や商品作り様々な
サービスを提供していく中でやっぱり失う
ことは寂しいけれどまスペースが空いた
から新しい人がそこに入ればいいわ最前の
選択をし続けてるるってことかな
ありがとうございますなんか
アチーブメントもその当初はおそらく採用
が強い会社だったかというと、ま、決して
強くはないところからスタートしたと思う
んですけれども、ある意味その、ま、強い
会社になっていく魅力を作るための
ファーストステップって何だと思われます
か?
基本的にはまず経営者が能力高いってこと
だよ。だ、自分がまず稼いで
自分のやっぱり最格である程度見通しを
自分がどれぐらい持てるかだよね。
僕はまず自分の中にあるから見通しが
で仕事のこの仕組みをしていったらこれだけの負荷加価値が生み出せるというのを考えれるのでその中から
の方式
っていうのを考え出したわけでね、ま、私が長年目標
達成の技術にはクローリッチナポレオンヒン哲学
[音楽]
の半権をね、全て独占券を得たり、ま、
そういうことによってブランドをきっちり
とつけていくとか、マーケティングだとか
私の中に
全てのいわゆる答えがあるんですよね。
その答えの中に一緒に働く人を豊かにする
という、それが繁栄の元だという答えを
持って経営しているので働く人から見たら
それは魅力だと思いますよ。だから僕が
どうしたら人を安く使えるかってことを
いつも考えていたとしたら相手から見たら
魅力のない経営者になり下がっちゃうわけ
じゃない。でも採用した以上はしっかりと
パフォーマンスを出してもらおうと。そこ
もやっぱりこだわりがあるよね。僕は3年
で給料の5倍のあらりを稼げる人間に
なれる仕組みを整えている。その仕組みを
作るのは私なんですよ。とうちの幹部です
よね。うちの幹部層がやっぱり優秀であれ
ば魅力的な会社っていうことになると思い
ます。
そうですね。だから採用の強い会社だっ
たらブランディング
あそこの会社に入りたいという気持ちを
学生自体が持ってるで、その理由は将来性
がある。それから自由裁量があって若くて
も早く出世できる。ま、そういう学生側の
視点から見た望みを叶えられる会社が魅力
のある会社で、学生側から見て見た魅力が
弱い会社がやっぱり採用が難しいと思っ
てる。でもその1番の元はやっぱり経営者
が投資をする覚悟を持ってるかどうかとか
結局は経営者がいやうちなんかいい人材
入らないよとかって思ってたらもうそれが
頭打ちじゃん。だ結局経営者なんだろうな
。魅力の元は経営者自身がやっぱりその
自分の会社がなぜ今世の中に必要なの
かっていうことをしっかりとプレゼンが
できるような経営者じゃないと厳しいん
じゃないかと思いますね。福利構成とか
休みの多給料
って福事的なもののような感じがする。
トータルな面で精神的にも経済的にも報わ
れるそういう会社で働きたいと人は思って
るってことだよね。ま、バイブルにはね、
何事でも人々からして欲しいと望む通りの
ことを他の人々にもそのようにしなさいと
。ま、これがマイデ7章12節の黄金率
っていうことなんだけど、この黄金率に
叶った仕事をしていったら必ず人が入り
たい会社が出来上がると思いますから、ま
、よくそこを深く深掘りしながら経して
もらえれば良いという風に思います。え、
コメント欄にもね、是非コメントも
いただきたいと思いますし、え、
チャンネル登録まだの方は是非ね、ポチっ
とチャンネル登録してください。また次回
お見に帰りましょう。ありがとうござい
ました。